سواء كان أسطورة لعبة الجولف تايجر وودز
التي تأتي والدتها كونتيدا من كانشانابوري
تايلاند ،
فهناك جزء من الشعب التايلاندي
ينظر إليه جميعًا لأنه
نصفنا في الأساس لاعب غولف تايلاندي محترف
تونغ تشاي جاي د مع 20
فوزًا احترافيًا تحت حزامه ، إنه جولة آسيوية
فازت الأسطورة بالجولة الأوروبية عدة
مرات وكنت محظوظًا جدًا
لمقابلته شخصيًا أو النجمة الصاعدة بادي
تافيرتانيكيت ، وهي من مواطني بانكوك ، والتي أصبحت
أول فائزة كبرى في بلدها في عام
2021 ، وهناك مصدر إلهام
في
تايلاند ينتج عنه أفضل المواهب
أعتقد أن الشيء مع لاعبى الجولف هو
أننا محظوظون للغاية
لأننا سنقيم بطولة
كل أسبوع ، وأعتقد أن الآباء يتمتعون
بقدر كبير من التنافس أيضًا ، لذا فهم
يدفعون الأطفال بقوة ، وأولئك الذين يخرجون
لا يزالون يحبون لعبة  أعتقد أن لعبة الجولف
يمكن أن تذهب بعيدًا حقًا ،
الملقب tk
هو إحساس بالغولف التايلاندي ، وهو عجائب يبلغ من العمر 15 عامًا
اختار نادٍ لأول مرة
في سن الثالثة  هـ ونصف
متأثرًا بشدة بوالده ،
كان والدي على وجه الخصوص
يحب اللعبة كثيرًا وقد تابعته للتو إلى
النطاق وبدأت في ضرب الكرات
البلاستيكية في الأندية البلاستيكية
ويبدو أنني كنت أطير بها جيدًا
ثم أدخلني في بعض الأندية المناسبة
بعد ذلك بقليل ، ثم
أخذني للمنافسة عندما كنت
في الرابعة من عمري قليلاً لأول مرة
كان والدي يحب النمر ، أشاهد
إعاداته ويخبرني قصصًا عن كل تلك
الإنجازات العظيمة التي كان
لقبها مزيجًا  من الأحرف الأولى
من أسماء والديه يقول إنه لا يزال
يتذكر خسارته الأولى
عندما كان في الرابعة من عمره ،
رأيت الطفل الذي حصل على الكأس
وشعرت بالغيرة حقًا ولم
أكن أعرف لماذا لم أحصل على واحدة لذلك كنت
كان منزعجًا حقًا ثم اضطر والدي إلى أن
يشرح لي كيف فاز ، لذا فقد حصل على
الكأس ، لذلك مارسني بشدة في الشهر التالي
وحصلت على
الكأس بعد ذلك ، لقد استمتعت
بذلك وأعتقد أنني طورت حبه
لـ  لعبة الجولف
التي تحب  لقد أخذته لعبة الجولف بعيدًا
في يناير ، فقد أصبح تقريبًا
أصغر فائز على الإطلاق في عمر 14 عامًا في الجولة الآسيوية
في سنغافورة الدولية ، وحصلت على
المركز الثالث في أول
حدث دولي للمحترفين على الإطلاق ، لذا كان ذلك
رائعًا